aujourd'hui c'est dimanche pourquoi ne
pas visiter une ferme et pourquoi pas
ici dans cet élevage caprin un peu
particulier bio mais pas que dans cette
exploitation le bien-être animal est une
priorité
ce qui permet à la ferme d'être
estampillé du label nature et progrès
les cornes
on respecte le cycle naturel de l'animal
des chèvres à cornes donc qui n'effraie
pas les enfants et qui semble en
parfaite santé
on parle beaucoup de bien être animal
c'est assez remis en question dans les
élevages et donc pouvoir montrer notre
notre métier qu'on peut vivre des
animaux en les respectant c'est quand
même quelque chose d'important
aujourd'hui à montrer et ce discours
plaît aux visiteurs sa démarche est
intéressante il n'a pas commencé comme
ça et puis finalement il s'est lancé là
dedans et je trouve que c'est bien la
visite pédagogique qui se poursuit sous
la pluie dans les jardin aromatique de
claire avant de se terminer dans son
atelier où sont confectionnés
je les ai eaux florales le journée riche
en échanges
pour nous c'est vraiment une occasion
importante d'accueillir des gens qui ont
vraiment nous aurait pas venir là ils
savent que on les attend on savent
qu'ils peuvent poser toutes les
questions qu'ils veulent même si c'est
des questions qui leur semblent naïve et
ça ça vraiment permet à plein plein de
gens les voisins mais déjà on devient là
il ya plein de familles de genre de tour
ou plus loin de doser venir dans une
ferme pour ceux qui auraient raté la
visite
la ferme est ouverte toute l'année et
vous attend